-We are all here
to play "Password"!
♪♪♪♪
-Have you looked at it?
-I did.
-Okay, okay. Ready?
-No.
[ Laughter ]
-Giggle.
-What?
[ Laughter ]
-Flipper.
-Dolphin.
-Wizthat.
-What?
[ Laughter ]
-Wizthat.
Si-iii-ing!
-Opera.
[ Ding! ]
-Boom!
-Yes!
-Gwah!
[ Laughter ]
-Diamonds.
-Gabagool.
[ Laughter ]
-Dog.
-Soup?
-Yes!
-Guacamole.
-Salad?
-Oh!
[ Vocalizes ]
-Chicken.
-Ohh!
-Meringue.
-Salsa.
-Oh!
-Call.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Booty?
-Yes!
-Leafy.
[ Laughter ]
-On the salad theme.
-Yeah, salad.
[ Laughter ]
Can't talk about anything else.
I never heard anyone talk about
salad more in their life.
[ Laughter ]
It's unbelievable.
A leafy, uh, uh...
[ Laughter ]
-Go ahead. You got it.
-I do have it?
-Yeah.
It's right at
the tip of your tongue.
[ Laughter ]
-Leafy...bush?
-Hey, no cheating.
-I'm not cheating!
-You can't use magic.
-Sorry, big...booty.
-I'm sorry.
Get your mind out of the gutter!
-I know. Last time --
-I don't want to hear it.
I do not want to hear it.
-Grimace.
-[ Grunting ]
[ Laughter ]
-Come on! Let's bring it home!
-Ganja.
[ Laughter ]
-Wait.
You did -- You thought --
-That confused him.
How did that make it worse?
[ Laughter ]
-What was the first one?
-We had a drumroll
for [bleep] sake.
[ Laughter ]
-Stort.
-Stort?
Stewart?
-Stewart.
-Stewart?
[ Laughter ]
-No, she's saying --
-Am I saying it right?
Stewart.
-Yes.
-Store it? Store it.
[ Laughter ]
-'Cause!
'Cause!
[ Laughter ]
-'Cause this is thriller!
[ Ding! ]